هي اخر التطورات المدنيه لحرب روسي على
اوكرانيا يوصلوا الجيش الاوكراني هجومه
المعاكسه في مقاطعه الدوناتسكا ولوغانسكا
واكد حكموا لوغانس الاوكراني ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على قريه
مكفيكا وبهذا يرتفعوا عدد البلدات التي
تمكن الجيش الاوكراني من استعانتها في
المقاطعه ل اثنتين 10 بلده ونقل مراسلنا
عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه استعادت استطاعت تحقيقه تقدم
وصفته بالطيف على محور اهداف وان خسائر
كبيره وقعت في صفوف المهاجمين ومن جهه
ثانيه كذا القوات ولبنت روسيا من الجيش
الاوكرانيه يوصلوا محاولاته الساعيه
لاقتحام خطوط الدفاع القوات الروسيه في
المقاطعه في منطقه خلصنا اكد المتحدث
باسمي هيئه الاركان الاخرانيه تدبيره
ومستودعه ذخيره للقوات الروسيه في الضفه
اليسرى لنهر دين برو وجنوبا الى ماريوب
اعلنا مستشار رئيسي بلديه المدينه ان
ارتالا كبيره مؤلفه من مئات المركبات
للجيش الروسي رصدت بالقرب من ماريوبالا
انا من دونالدز كم مراسله الجزيره امين
نادرغامي امين يعني ما زالت خيرسون هي
محور الاهتمام واا محطه الاضواء الرئيس
الاوكراني زاره خيرسون ليؤكد انها عاده
لسيطره القوات الاكرانيه ما الذي يقال في
روسيا عن هذا الانسحاب من منطقه همم يفترض
انها صوتت للانضمام لروسيا
من الناحيه العسكريه زين وزاره الدفاع
كانت قد اظهرت واعلنت بشكل واضح عن
الاسباب التي دفعتها الى اتخاذ هذا القرار
الذي وصفته في المقابل بانه صعب لكنه
ضروري ضمن خطط استراتيجيه كان لابد من
اتخاذها في هذا التوقيت
الان وايضا خلال مرحله همم وجيزه جدا من
ايام باعتبار انها سحبت 30,000 عسكري
واكثر من خمسه الاف قطعه عسكريه من
المدرعات والاليات من تلك المنطقه همم في
غضون ثلاثه ايام فقط بالرغم من ان بعض
المصادر التي كانت قبل ذلك تتحدث عن
انسحاب قوات روسيه من هناك لكن الروس
يقولون بانهم ما زالوا حتى الان يسيطرون
على 70% من مجموع مساحه خرسون باعتبار ان
الضفه اليمنى التي انسحبت منها القوات
الروسيه لا تشكل الا اا من 30%
والان همم ضربه مع التعويل الكبير هو ان
تنتقل همم وحدات من تلك القوات التي
انسحبت الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر النيبرو
الى جبهات اخرى لا تقل الاهميه عن جبهه
خرسون وهنا الحديث على عن هذه الجبهه جبهه
دونياسك حيث نحن والتي يقول المواليون
لروسيا وايضا القوات الروسيه بانها تحقق
تقدما كبيرا همم
السيطره على عدد كبير من البلدات في محيط
مطار دنياسكو قبل قليل فقط وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت عن السيطره الكامله على
بلده بابلوكا في جنوبي مدينه دمياط وهي
بلده متاخمه لمدينه اوبلادار والاغماء
الاشارات هنا على ان الهجوم القادم في هذا
المحور سيكون على مدينه اوبلدار
الاستراتيجيه سياسيا اليوم سئل الى
المتحدث باسم الكربلائي ايسكو عن همم يعني
موقف موسكو من زياره زيليسكي قال بان اا
بانه لن يعلق على هذه الزياره واكد من
جديد على ان اخرصون هي اراضي روسيا ضمن
تلك الاراضي طبعا التي ضمتها روسيا قبل
نحو شهرين بعد ذلك هناك ايضا همم
لاحقا اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
هجمات في شرق البلاد شكرا